the lobby of Ramsey solutions clay and
as arena are with us hey guys how are
you
man we deserve welcome welcome where do
you guys live Atlanta Georgia well
welcome to Nashville here to do your
debt-free scream I assume yes sir great
how much have you paid off ninety six
thousand six hundred dollars I love it
and how long did it take you to do that
just over two years Wow impressive
making what kind of money during that
time starting out at around 1:30 and at
the end around 1:40 good for you what do
you guys do for a living she's an
engineer and I'm a freight guy cool very
cool so what kind of debt was this as
arena
it was mostly mortgage no you paid off
your house yeah I love that that's cool
we didn't have a lot of you know student
loan debt or credit card debt like a lot
of people do but what really got us was
as soon as we graduated University of
Tennessee metal walls evolved now we did
what every other college graduate did
and went drove on a new car off the lot
with a car note sure and I like that new
car smell so much that as soon as it
went away I went got me a new one and I
kept doing that every two years and it
just kind of held its back even though
you know my dad had sacrificed a lot to
kind of get us started out real good you
know just the new cars and car notes is
what held us back so okay so how much of
the 97 thousand was car dad well it was
only thirteen thousand she had whittled
it down by the time you get ready start
this yeah I actually listen to the show
ever since I started working right out
of college it took a lot of years of
what what kind of a switch fly up to 24
months ago I think it was one time on
the air when I heard you talking about
what it feels like to be debt-free and
going into work and over update work and
be like you know what I got no payments
you know now that we're there I you know
I realized like it really is a something
else it's like a
huge weight lifted off of our shoulders
and it makes those rough days at work
not so rough because you just you know
you're not you don't feel like you know
there's no way out and you know you just
kind of opens up a whole new world yeah
sure it's a different feeling you feel a
whole lot more in control you got
different options when you don't have
any payments
so as arena he comes home and says we're
gonna pay off the house we're going on a
hardcore plan for two years what do you
say I'm okay with that because we
haven't really changed our lifestyle you
know since college we don't go up much
to restaurants we don't shop a lot so it
was kind of easy for us so you just kind
of had to focus on it then yeah yeah
just just putting a plan on paper and
you know coming up with a timeline for
it we actually finished a couple months
easy earlier than we projected just
because you know once you can see the
the finish line you know it's like we
really want to go out tonight yeah well
you can see that yellow tape over there
I want to run through it that's the
thing yeah very cool guy it's very cool
how's it feel done I have a house
payment any payments of any kind in the
world it's incredible
just it's hard to describe just the
freedom mmm and and I think the title
your first book that I read financial
piece you know that term right there is
what it's all about
amen amen very cool guys very cool
what's the house worth it's worth around
150 now are when we signed the note on
it it was I think 192 but you know
thanks to the generosity of my family we
headed down I can't really claim credit
for that part getting down to 83 but
yeah we just hammered it down from there
excellent well very cool you too way to
go all right clay and as arena Atlanta
Georgia $97,000 paid off in two years
they paid off their house and everything
making a hundred and thirty now making
140 count it down let's hear a debt free
scream three two
one we're debt-free yes way to go you
guys way to go
awesome job Wow that is awesome